video premiere auf bild.de die haudegen
sind sich aber auch für nicht so fies
wir aber auch nicht wir legen den
gesalzenen finger in die wunde und
fragen danach und noch nach viel mehr
unangenehmen jetzt infrage not mit den
augen wieder spaß hat auch mal sein ende
und das ist jetzt mit dem fragen otto
hoffentlich der fall
wir haben uns wieder gedanken gemacht
bei unseren heutigen gästen wie wir
gegen dieses mal so richtig auf die
palme bringen können mit unseren
korrektur männer foto ach das kann
natürlich sein jetzt wird wer aber
erstmalig also rot grüne fragen die
grünen sind harmlose fragen die roten
sind gemeinde fragen ihr könnt selber
entscheiden
auf euch fein ziseliert haben wie sie
gemeinsam und wir hoffen dass er jetzt
mal richtig
versuch mal die roten rosen brauchen wir
noch
du stellst du unsere erste aktuelles
video wurde zuerst auf bild.de
veröffentlicht kann man noch tiefer
sinken
die frage kann er ja mal und jugendjahre
beantworten
bild.de ist ja wirklich führen muss man
mal sagen nachrichtenübermittlung an die
menschen dort draußen führen also alle
die sagen er bild und so die leser serra
behält also die typen designszene bild
ist mir zu platt
die lesen selber bild bei uns ist es so
wir wollen das ding so an so viele
menschen wie möglich an getragen wird um
wirklich zu verändern unsere texte an
die leute zu bringen und deshalb es hat
auch youtube die herner mal die bild
bild dir deine meinung
okay da gibt's ja auch andere meinungen
zu allem ja stimmt du merkst wie wir
beschränken uns auf die roten
ich merke das schon eine tolle dinge ich
kann eure schmutz wie einsam er brav
gegeben von harten rap zu mainstream
rock wann kommt das erste album mit
david guetta das kommt auf die anfrage
läuft auf jeden fall also david guetta
wenn du bock hast mit haudegen innovativ
kreativ und leidenschaftlich musik zu
machen bei uns an
wir haben auf jeden fall muss auch sagen
in 16 70er jahren viel mehr
internationale künstler und auf deutsch
gesungen absolut italiener petula clark
kent heute kein mensch mehr aber auch in
start ups hat ohne ende
deutsch gesungen natürlich als erwartet
grün zu langweilig die dicke foto so
verständlich ihr lasst euch jeden
blödsinn tätowieren hasst ihr euren
körper so sehr wir lieben ihn wir lieben
ihn und deswegen machen wir immer
schöner das ding ist aus dem tor durch
eine laune passieren kann er hat kann
auch sein dass er nächste woche im
westen auf der hand tätowieren lassen
wäre so recht warum ich eigentlich schon
genau da kommt aus einer laune heraus
oder kann auch sein dass ich wenn ich
morgens irgendwie denke man so ein
marienkäfer also mariechen kündigungen
wie schön ja dann las ich mit all ihren
natürlich im endeffekt die zum
einzigartigkeit und jeder mensch hat
bedürfnis nach einzigartigkeit und wenn
du ihn oder innovativ ist und kreativ
bist dann solltest du darauf acht geben
dass du einzigartig ist und ganz ehrlich
letztens hat jemand einen guten spruch
zu mir gesagt ja gesagt alte haut sieht
so nah so scheiße so viel mit katona
kleine grüne das reicht dann auch fähig
und wollweiß ultra ihr geht musikalisch
mit dem kopf durch die wand stehen eure
alten fans noch zu euch ja natürlich tun
sie weil sie weil ihnen weil im
endeffekt ist uns an unseren alten fans
egal welche musik mache ich brauche sie
wissen einfach was wir für menschen sind
sie personifizieren uns und sagen ich
glaube das schlimmste was wir machen
könnten wäre schlager dann würden solche
wahrscheinlich auch die alten leute am
kopf kratzen
aber ich glaube sonst system menschen
die uns schon so viele jahre begleiten
egal was wir machen weil sie einfach
wissen wie wir ticken und ganz im
gegenteil sich die hinter uns und sagen
heute mit stolz wissen möchtest du mir
die gerne vorlesen
ihr geht euren weg ohne kompromisse was
macht euch stark schöne anschlussfrage
absolut der glaube an uns selbst der
glaube an uns an unsere an unsere
fähigkeiten fähigkeiten wir haben vor
kurzem so schönen satz wir haben dir
macht man ii konnten
der ist ein schöner satz acht wagen
irgendwann mal zu mir da bist du ja
irgendwie wird ja singen können ja jetzt
auch so schön berlin seine leidenschaft
in melodie packen könnte und ich sage du
kannst noch singen der sagt ich hab noch
nie probiert ich saddam solltest mal
probieren mit künstlern menschen ist
wenn er sich verändern möchte muss er
sich trauen können um sich trauen zu
können musste arsch in der hose haben
und musste auch leute an deiner seite
haben die den rücken stärken wenn du
vielleicht gerade so haben umfallen bist
also musste ich trauen trau dich einfach
mal trau dir ded zu weil andere nie von
dir erwarten und schon bis zur
versicherung seite dazu ist ein schönes
schlusswort und in dem sinne seien
vielen dank für die fragen diana amft
musste weinen ich hab mir nämlich also
nicht in fragen leute aber sie musste
weinen weil sie von 12 schauspielschulen
abgelehnt worden ist und das habe ich
ihr im fragen london natürlich aufs
butterbrot geschmiert nasa dagegen habe
ich aufs butterbrot geschmiert dass er
immer noch klein kinderseelen kopfweh
dragon ball z oder batman und er hat
eigentlich ganz gutes argument batman
sei doch gar nicht für kinder
wer sich sonst noch verteidigt auch bei
den anderen gemeinden fragen im fragen
motto mit ihm viel spaß